this convoy is enroute to an area along
Highway 15 between Benoit and bung tau a
coastal resort town at the mouth of the
Saigon River some 65 kilometers
southeast of Saigon its mission is to
establish a forward command post from
which a multiple armed Search and
Destroy operation by elements of the 1st
Infantry Division will be controlled it
is January 28 and operation malice is
beginning as the forward CP nears
operational status and while artillery
batteries are occupying positions nearby
Chinook helicopters begin arriving with
assault troops
at the CP area these units of the first
Infantry reassemble and await the
arrival of uh-1 helicopters
the Huey's will carry the troops into
the initial attack against the Vietcong
other infantry companies were carried by
Huey's from staging areas near their
base of operations directly to assault
position
from the landing zones the units deploy
and move forward in a westward sweep
through the jungle the purpose of
operation mallet was to hunt and kill or
capture Viet Cong guerrillas operating
in this area some 35 kilometers east of
Saigon and to destroy their camps and
hideaways
on the first day of operation mallet
this unit of the first infantry was
filmed as it burned deserted huts used
by the VC after conferring with a unit
commander a forward observer departs in
an old 13 light observation helicopter
he will help provide aerial surveillance
for the advancing troops the units
continue their sweep through the area
and move off narrow trails for probes
through dense jungle in the late
afternoon when this unit had forged
within 4,000 meters of its designated
resupply area it came under fire from
well concealed Vietcong snipers air
strikes and artillery support against
the objective were requested the unit
withdrew for the night after one man was
killed and reconnaissance had indicated
a large complex of bunkers and tunnels
on the following morning January 29 us
and Vietnamese Air Force planes hips the
bunker complex with bombs
as the air strike send the supporting
artillery units begin bombarding the
objective
when the artillery fire shifts units of
the 1st infantry move out and converge
from different directions upon the
objective area the units encountered no
resistance as they cautiously entered
the maze of bunkers but the area was
laced with trip wires leading to booby
traps located in trees and huts the
troops threw hand grenades into the vast
network of bunkers and tunnels which
honey combed the area they then made a
thorough search of all bunkers and huts
no Vietcong were found and it was
assumed that they had slipped out during
the night before the airstrike taking
most of their weapons and equipment with
them however a sizable cash of paperwork
medical supplies food some clothing and
training literature was captured
pertinent items were forwarded to g2 for
interpretation the deserted compound was
believed to be a district political camp
housing some 30 bc
three days later on februari first other
elements of the first infantry were
filmed as they continued operation
mallet the sweep westward has now
brought units to an area some 16
kilometers east of Saigon late in the
afternoon the units encountered heavy
fire plus numerous mines and booby traps
the sweep forward is halted supporting a
pcs and tanks cover a withdrawal of
several hundred meters here while
tactical air strikes are requested the
wound that are given emergency treatment
and evacuated
after the air strikes which could be
seen from the tallest buildings in
Saigon artillery and mortar fires were
called on to the objective areas
throughout the night on the following
day February's second resistance was
again encountered after additional air
strikes and artillery support however
the first infantry units over ran the
complex of fortifications with no
opposition examination of the badly
damaged bunkers showed that much of the
VC base camp area apparently had been
constructed recently much of the turned
earth had not yet settled firmly around
the fortifications some of the bunkers
were uncovered by a dozer blade mounted
on a tank retriever meanwhile demolition
experts prepared multiple block
explosive charges of comp see the
labyrinth of bunkers and tunnels was
destroyed these units of the 1st
infantry then moved out to establish a
new CP area from which to continue
operation mallet
this unit of the Republic of Korea's
Tiger division was filmed as it moved
out of its base camp area to begin a
combat patrol against the Viet Cong the
unit one of several ROK forces serving
in South Vietnam was based along Highway
19 some 55 kilometers northwest of Queen
yon this action took place in
mid-december 1965 as the unit advance
that came under light small arms fire
from the VC to disperse the guerrillas
machine guns and recoilless rifles in
addition to individual weapons or use
as soon as sporadic sniper fire is
silenced the unit continues its march
its mission on this Patrol is to search
out and destroy any Vietcong in the
village of Ponton located approximately
5 kilometers east of the unit's base of
operations women children and other
non-hostile villagers were rounded up
some were given food while their houses
were searched for Viet Cong or military
equipment following instructions the
Patrol then begins evacuating all
residents from the village
all the villagers approximately 130
persons were reported as families of
Viet Cong guerrillas they were moved by
the Korean unit to a refugee center some
distance away in a subsequent operation
other units of the tiger division board
helicopters for the start of a mission
they are flown to an area approximately
64 kilometers north of queenie on from
this landing zone the korean set out on
a combat patrol
at the edge of the zone the men pause
and await the word to move out and seek
the enemy at base camp a helicopter
arrives bringing the chairman of the US
Joint Chiefs general Earl G wheeler for
a visit with a tiger division he is
greeted by ranking ROK officers general
weyler proceeds to the tiger division
area there he holds discussions with a
division commander Major General Chaim
Jung shin and his staff
elements of the 2nd Marine Division
Republic of Korea are assigned certain
security and protection missions in the
cam ranh bay area of South Vietnam these
include guarding the port facilities and
the new Air Base near by one of the ROK
units is deployed near the narrow neck
of the cam ranh bay peninsula from their
base camp the Marines conduct patrols
against the VC they also man observation
posts along the bay shore the overall
function of this unit is to prevent
infiltration by land another unit
deployed on what is known as the south
peninsula uses 106 recoilless rifles to
control the mouth of the bay it's
location is also designed to prevent
Viet Cong from bringing mortars within
range of installations on the opposite
shore reconnaissance conducted by the
ROK units includes that on the bay
itself here patrols move out in two US
Army larks for a routine check on both
movement in the bay and adjacent waters
these water patrols are designed to halt
both smuggling and VC activity on the
bay
native fishing boats junks and other
crafts are searched for weapons
contraband or any guerrilla material as
a precautionary measure many small craft
and their occupants who even though from
all appearances are harmless are also
routinely searched another ROK unit is
deployed near the pontoon bridge that
connects the peninsula to the mainland
near highway 1 its mission includes
routine checks of civilian traffic on
highway 1 and the protection of allied
traffic on the mainland approach to the
bridge
President Johnson and his chief
diplomatic and military advisors arrived
in honolulu on februari fifth for an
historic three-day conference with the
leaders of South Vietnam in announcing
the conference's President Johnson
indicated that their purpose would be a
review of our complete program in
Vietnam including economic social and
political subjects as well as military
ones among those accompanying the
president our defense secretary McNamara
and the Secretary of State Dean Rusk as
well as other key cabinet members and
top-level officials on the following day
the presidential party returns to
Honolulu International Airport to
welcome the top Vietnamese leaders
arriving from Saigon
heading the vietnamese delegation or the
chief of state Lieutenant General no
Infante you and air vice-marshal million
kalki the Prime Minister
you
President Johnson and general Chu broke
the line
next mr. Johnson will make an address
welcoming the Vietnamese leaders and
briefly outlining the objectives of the
conference the President of the United
States we meet here in a time of testing
and proud but we will talk also of hope
and harvest our friends in Korea and
Australia and New Zealand have sent
their own men to join with Vietnamese
and American in a conflict to decide if
aggression and Tara are the way of the
future are whether free men are to
decide their own course general q
Vietnamese chief of state gives the
response mr. silly Thank You mr.
president for the world and heartening
welcome which you have extended to us
and we take this opportunity to
reiterate the solemnity of the
Vietnamese people to continue and fight
this war for as long as is necessary and
to be willing and ready to make
sacrifices so as not to betray all those
who crave Americans and Vietnamese who
have given their lives so that we may be
free
as the welcoming ceremonies em the
chiefs of State and delegates depart on
the previous day General William C
Westmoreland held a press conference on
the military situation in Vietnam your
estimate of the number of indigenous
South Vietnamese that are engaging our
troops in South Vietnamese food
purchaser what percentage are from
northfield well approximately one-third
of the regimental of the regiment's that
we carry in our order of battle or North
Vietnamese organizations and of the
total battalions that we carry
approximately twenty-five percent of our
North Vietnamese he attacks by large
units have not been as great during the
last several weeks as was the case
during november and december but they
after the vietnamese leaders arrived the
president's motorcade heads for camp
smith where the work of the honolulu
conference will begin a plenary meeting
will be followed by working sessions on
all major topics
arriving at saigon stanza nude airport
on january first for a five-day
inspection tour of army facilities and
operations in vietnam his secretary of
the army stanley research he is greeted
by General William C Westmoreland and
members of his command a briefing at the
first logistical Command headquarters
was followed by an inspection of
warehousing and shipping activities at
the Saigon port area at phu loi some 150
kilometers southwest of Saigon secretary
resour talks with members of an aviation
unit and inspects new armament and armor
used with you h1 helicopters I on the
topics of discussion were the problems
of resupply two units fighting 7,000
miles from their homeland during his
tour secretary resources you nuts in the
Benoit on K and play KU areas
on january twenty fourth of the saigon
airport Lieutenant General John a junta
jizz deputy commander Mac be and members
of his staff welcome lieutenant general
Jean angler to his new assignment in
Vietnam after the airport ceremonies
general angler reviews a color guard in
his honor and is introduced to members
of his future staff he assumes his new
duties as deputy commander of the US
Army Vietnam this position recently
upgraded was previously held by
Brigadier General John T Norton now
serving as general anglers chief of
staff general English previous
assignment was in Washington as
commanding general of the supply and
maintenance command
as a major part of the build up at Cam
Ranh Bay elements of the u.s. army
engineers are constructing a number of
new type warehouses on 15 January we see
engineers prepare forms into which
concrete will be poured to establish
footings as this phase proceeds
bulldozers level the surrounding area
Vietnamese workmen have been hired to
assist this type of construction from
its large storage areas in this case 200
by 250 feet to be built with a minimum
of materials at the same time they
incorporate the strength and durability
needed to withstand the severe winds and
rains common to the area the supporting
beams and girders are secured before the
roofing is begun in the final stage of
construction long sheets of corrugated
rust-proof metal are used to cover the
warehouse the thin but durable roofing
material permits a much lighter
supporting structure to be used saving
both time and expense the speed of
construction enables the army to provide
substantial storage facilities in a
short space of time traffic in the
vicinity of Cam Ranh Bay is handled by
the US Army Military Police they form
part of the overall security for the
area with special emphasis on the piers
and the village one section they patrol
is the fence which marks the limit of
the military reservation vendors stalls
are built close against the barbed wire
during vending hours sales are made
directly through the fence a warning in
Korean that beyond the fence is off
limits the American sign with a similar
message informed soldiers at the village
of Cam Ranh is closed to them jeeps are
used to patrol the roads and terrain in
their jurisdiction
on 28 January 1966 cargo vessels are
docked at Cam Ranh Bay to be unloaded
the unloading and storage of the
materials is handled by transportation
and logistical units at the Harbor large
five ton trailer trucks are used to
handle the volume empty trucks are
backed into position so that when fully
loaded they may drive straight forward
callette loads of C rations are raised
from the hold of the ship and swung over
side directly on to the waiting trucks
they are immediately driven to one of
the several storage areas nearby
all the techniques of material handling
and the latest mechanical equipment
speed the movement of supplies which
pour through in heavy volume but even
modern equipment encounters problems
this large truck tries to fight its way
out of the sandy harbor Shore it makes
slow progress until it is pushed by
another piece of equipment not
handicapped by a heavy load u.s. army
engineers are making improvements on cam
ranh bay harbor this project required
they're working on a raft made of two
boats / together because it involved the
laying of a pipeline over the water the
line is needed to drain waste to a more
distant point methods were improvised on
the spot to perform this difficult pass
the pipe is manhandled into place by men
who must simultaneously maintain their
balance on the boat
as they work almost in the shadow of
ships unloading at DeLong fear the men
are preparing this most important Harbor
for the heavy demands of future shipping
operational maintenance is performed on
the caribou by members of the aviation
company even though it is late January
of 1966 the climate from its outdoor
servicing a landing gear wheel is
replace the engine housing is secured
after inspection has been completed
recording is made in the logbook of the
details of the servicing at the aviation
companies installation at suck trong the
engine is tested before restoring the
plane to active operation the caribou
with its short takeoff and landing
capability is a particular value in
Vietnam
this is the Latin American military
communication system site at Guatemala
City its antenna and transmitter tied
into a worldwide communication system
through the hub station in the Canal
Zone the operation of this station is
being taken over by an all civilian crew
provided by a contractor military
personnel are being phased out teletype
as well as voice transmissions are
handled through the board the operators
also perform maintenance channels of
transmission can be quickly checked and
corrections made if needed the
officer-in-charge reviews with the
civilian contractors representative
specific details of the conversion to
civilian operation a counterpart of the
installation we have just seen is the
lantus station at Managua Nicaragua this
site built by an American contractor
began operation in May 1964 although now
operated by civilians the station is
under military supervision
the American Embassy and other us
offices in the capital city have the
advantage of the most modern
communications here in Nicaragua
in February 1966 these Vietnamese flee
their homes to avoid the Vietcong in
their flights they carry food and a few
of their possessions because the
Vietcong often travel amid innocent
groups Korean military police are
checking the refugees for weapons or
enemy documents until this year the
Vietcong used this area as one of their
main supply sources taking half of the
11 million tonne output of rice
trucks are provided to carry the
refugees to the relative safety of the
town as part of their assignment to
provide area security the Koreans
include 105 millimeter howitzers in
their equipment the battery commander
supervises the gun team
the men inspected Viet Cong equipment
captured on the previous operation it
includes weapons and boxes of ammunition
also bicycles which are an important
means of transportation to the Viet Cong
grenades and flares are included in the
captured supplies there were many
personal effects and articles of
clothing the korean marines clean their
weapons in preparation for their
assigned duties in the cam ranh bay area
which include protection of Allied base
camps port facilities airfield and
allied support installations each
location is systematically prepared for
defense emplacements and positions are
improved to withstand any possible
attack monir emplacements are prepared
and Fox holes are dug close to machine
guns attending a briefing our Major
General Stanley Larsen commanding
general of field forces Vietnam and
Brigadier General Lee of the Korean
Marine Corps the subject is operation
van buren which is providing rice
harvest security in the area south of
TUI wha
near cuchi some 40 kilometers northwest
of saigon elements of the 25th Infantry
Division encounter heavy Viet Cong
mortar and rifle fire on February night
in one of their first engagements with
the enemy since arriving in Vietnam
you